yeah welcome to this video playing a
grandmaster sleep ugh i recently won
against him a big boob yet game where i
played the opening really badly and then
he somehow managed to get his contract
okay um i went for the the bank oh I'm
trying to try to play um this is matt
ft7 Linus's an idea against this rook p1
fianchetto setup which is very dangerous
brooke be one but i'm not really sure
what the big point of the Hospice's i'm
just playing it ok here it seems that
he's just trying to prepare you for yeah
i think i think this is what blacks
ideas what is what is it doing now the
good question
okay so should I go 95 and tending 93 it
looks quite good I i also had rook da da
Queen a fight or something but intending
to go to d3 cannot be so bad he he also
cannot play Bishop everyone let's say
Knight takes Knight takes bishop
everyone because of night on yeah yeah I
thought he needs to do this but okay
with this with this Bishop I I can
hardly be worse yeah I should i take it
actually yeah maybe it's probably miss
placing pieces look all the king don't
want want them to move yeah this looks
like very good compensation for the pole
yeah this is a defensive move it's not
designed to attack or something it just
wants to protect the the c39 the a black
has got very nice pressure I'm not sure
how we should defend now
if I go queen bee farm yeah looks good
be to hanks and I'm not sure how it's
going to to defend now be three also can
place you fall okay yeah well I can I
can just take it it's not it's not
really bad and big be too but they're
not sure that I really want to do that
at the end is going to play a form and
it's probably nothing nothing's nothing
spectacular hmm
ah wait wait wait wait wait what about
Bishop g4 rook d3 looked III Bishop b2
night be too Queen takes every check why
this is strong now this is strong
actually oh yeah this I didn't really
expect but maybe it's not so terrible i
can go here i can go here here attacking
evil and putting some pressure on f2 I
need to check this line that i
calculated afterwards if if it really
was working quite noise
yeah this is a very ugly position of
course for what yeah hmm yeah come on
keep it simple this is good for for for
an edge and should i should do this okay
how to play now I go yeah that's just
let's just take it I can take on on III
it's not paid at all I'm not sure maybe
I can even get both pawns this would be
even easier I can play we play 94 now i
should have taken that I should have
taken not so easy this decision of
course it would if I take it it really
ruins the spawn structure but you have
nots you form let's see for rock p3 what
okay taking on v3 would lead to a
self-tan cannot do that
mmm yeah I should have taken you three
this was really stupid very very bad
technical flame
yeah one way positive feature of the
porn structures I'm getting my bishop
trip to vary in your tech yeah this is
great yeah yeah King f1 and he's not
playing this exactly great okay yeah you
too little free this bishop
what a game yeah I losing this is really
heartbreaking the sungood completely
dead end game for what time morning just
need to take a three and I'm never ever
losing this
I finally found it and what I mean some
people what I know I mean drawing him
yeah okay I bet I better keep my mouth
shut here I came I mean this was really
I mean ok yeah the problem is here I
mean I have so many good good
possibilities that I wasn't really sure
what to do wait Simone it's not working
ok so here take stakes yeah until I pro
should probably just take it I mean this
is not this you willing recapture I mean
you play to really really bad but he
would he would have recaptured ok and
now this is just a very one-sided
endgame of course where black is much
better but I wasn't so sure how I'm
going to win this this is why I didn't
didn't go for that he's his consisting
of weaknesses but he can play something
like this and a position like this it's
not it's not so clear how to how to
improve but I should go for this black
can never ever lose it and I'm just
better and can can try to to make some
progress
in the game of course I'm also better
but it's not it's not so easy and of
course he just played it very badly you
could have gotten the Knight to c4 and
all kinds of stuff then yeah yeah I need
to be an i need to be more more modest I
tried to do something he played kingi
two wins he didn't see that of course
and now i miss King f1 winning okay I
needed to do that maybe the hour and
this is now no loss but he played this
so badly that at the end it was a draw
but I lost some time I should take you
three year this is really really bad
here take III and I can never lose it's
just a bad practical decision if I play
this um it's easy to play and um it has
no risk involved whatsoever yeah thanks
for watching